what time
show up at jail in santo boma
his wife says he has no intention of doing that either
to do because it 1
political fondus would have been
they wanted to be called
even though of
Got 20 years for his role in December
murders in 1982
misstaatverslaggever
John of the Hill
has for clarity and 19
8215 opponents of the regime arrested
tortured and executed
so today that prison sentence would go against him
yes what will happen now
yes that's 1 good question uh
there will be 1 uh
care investigations must take place
uh at least you would normally expect that
only in Suriname
things don't always happen the way you do
with uh with our expectation pattern uh would expect
so uh yeah it's actually really exciting
1 few uh things may have happened
or uh bouders uh
is hiding somewhere in his own country
and he has enough places and also enough people who uh
support him in this
or he has now
the weeks taken to 1 other country
with which there is no subsistence
then you think of Cuba or Venus wela wherever uh
yes friends
relationships of his remain
Uhm yes it can go in any direction
yes we record this on uh friday uh afternoon
Uhm how big is the chance that it also leads to uh
disturbances in Suriname
suppose IE itself for example
hides in the country
he also has
many followers
and that can lead to some confrontations
the latter certainly uh in uh
the run-up to uh eventually the end
in Suriname uh there is 1 uh
leaked from the police intelligence diet in
Suriname uh
we have there in the telegraph
testity paid such attention to it
and from that information 1
report can be drawn up very clearly
there is actually 1 bit listed
who are fellow positions and uh
what can possibly be expected
and from that you could already conclude that there is uh
yes even uh armed hand
perhaps resistance would be offered
uh that report also lead to
to unrest in Suriname
and uh that could actually happen now
he also called uh that 1 number of members of his
political parties and DP
would gather at his villa this morning uh om
yes to show 1 kind of support
Uhm and and the moment he is now tracked down and
possibly to 1 prison
transferred yes then you can expect everything
so it is really 1 tense situation now in Suriname
but I speak there
I regularly speak to people there yes also uh within uh
from the police and the judiciary uh from politics
and you just see
that everyone is actually walking on eggs
uh to keep it all lowkey
but yes this does not help
no I asked myself
off if you are talking about the country of Suriname
and about the authorities
are they then capable
to this uh
to lead in the right direction and under
keep control
well that's 1 uh tricky question uh
look uh at the moment when there really uh
babbled resistance is going to come
which you should not exclude
yes then then the question is how far uh uh
the army and the police in Suriname
is capable because
because great times and it is
that is also described in that report
it is also true that
construction still has a following
within the police and within the army
So
there is also 1 last year
stormed the parlament
in Suriname
and it just showed that
yes yes uh that even worked together by certain uh
figures from the army to uh
make those protests possible
and uh in that sense that is very uncertain yes
while again to some images of eh bouders eh
from looking earlier
so much eh unrest there in Suriname
now you also hear the scenario of the jungle
you can of course go there to hide in eh
Suriname but that is 1 real scenario
family eh
the age eh of bouders eh and his health eh
situation
well everything is possible of course but he is uh
he doesn't have your problems uh
should even be formalized uh
regularly uh
so you really just have to do that in 1
do in 1 hospital or in 1 clinic
so yes that chance is not very big Uhm
I think IE is just somewhere in one place uh
where those possibilities are there
and uh yes that IE right now uh
is not very hungry
in 1 prison or in 1 uh special shelter
what would be built for him in Suriname to uh
to close uh the last days of his life
yes i don't know
uh images have surfaced of 1 kind of uh
yes it would like to call almost 1 kind of doghouse
what on the uh
train of it
military hospital in paramarbo is now being built
yes if you see that and you
you know you might just be there for years to come
uh get locked up
IE does not feel like it immediately
but it also gives something uh
it also says something about his morality
of course he always said yes no I uh
inform me of this process
and I inform myself to the rule of law Suriname uh
and now finally it is judgment
and what happens next
uh he he uh yes he disappears from 1 stage
he leaves his wife then 1 groups
he is not coming because it is all 1 political process
yes it says something about it
about uh how this guy stands Erin and yeah yeah
let's hope
that at least the sour-name government
and the whole uh
the whole uh justice apparatus right there
is able to do it anyway
to ensure that the right ultimately has its lead
because I think that's something
what you sure for uh
also for the next of kin of uh
the victims of those December murders
should hope and expect
ok John thank you thank you